let's calculate the kinetic energy in
the center-of-mass frame of two objects
that are colliding I'm going to use
prime for the center of mass frame
velocity so we have v1 Prime and we have
the two Prime and recall two things that
when we calculated v1 prime in the
center-of-mass frame we found that this
was equal to the reduced mass divided by
m1 times the relative velocities of the
two objects v1 prime minus v2 Prime now
in the center-of-mass frame this quant
this quantity is a reference frame
independent and so we can just write
that as the 1/2 it's the relative
velocity is reference frame independent
so we also knew that the two prime was
equal to minus mu over m to the 1/2
so now let's calculate the kinetic
energy in the center-of-mass frame so KC
M is one-half m1 v1 prime squared plus
one-half m2 v2 prime squared now let's
use our results in terms of relative
velocity so we have one-half m1 mu over
m1 times v1 2 squared because we're
squaring that plus one-half m2 new the
minus sign doesn't matter anymore
because we're squaring it b2 squared I
could put that in there it wouldn't
matter and now what we have is we have a
have one of the M ones cancels so we
have a Mew squared over m1 v1 2 squared
plus 1/2 another Mew squared over m2
times v1 2 squared so I pull out the
common terms mu squared B 1/2 squared I
have 1 over m 1 plus 1 over M 2 but
recall that the reduced mass was
precisely 1 over m 1 plus 1 over m 2 and
so I get 1/2 mu times V 1 2 squared is
the kinetic energy in the center-of-mass
frame so what that means is a way of
thinking if this were just a simple
reduced mass problem with the relative
speed of V 1 2 squared I can write down
the kinetic energy but that's the
kinetic energy in the center-of-mass
frame and therefore the change in
kinetic energy is in a collision is just
1/2 the 1/2 the initial final squared -
and it's the same mu so we'll just put a
- b12 initial squared and if the
collision is elastic remember our
elastic collision showed that v1 to
initial was - the one - final so an
elastic collision satisfies that
condition and you can see directly that
Delta K cm is zero in that case and a
completely inelastic collision has the
two objects moving together at the end
so v1 - final is zero so completely
inelastic is the condition that v1 to
final is zero because the objects stick
together and then we have a very simple
result for the change in kinetic energy
for completely inelastic collision it's
only negative one-half mu B 1 - initial
quantity squared